le sujet est très sérieux mais votre
légèreté al traité m'amène à vous poser
une charade
mon premier est une commune de
loire-atlantique
mon deuxième est le résultat d'un fiasco
politique du quinquennat précédent
mon troisième est une zone de 1600
hectares où les forces de l'ordre
républicaine ont été interdits de
circuler et pourtant le facteur
portaient les courriers des à dist en
droit de toucher les aides sociales
mon quatrième est une zone où le droit
de propriété bafoué par des à dist
construisant des abris en toute
illégalité mantoue est une zone de non
droit où nos forces de l'ordre sont
attaquées alors qu'elles accomplissent
avec courage leur mission en angle état
vendredi dernier avec le ministre d'état
ministre de l'intérieur je me suis rendu
sur la commune de saint-etienne de
montluc pour rencontrer les gendarmes
les pompiers
les membres du parquet de nantes et de
saint-nazaire qui concourent aux
opérations et qui le font avec un
professionnalisme avec un calme face à
des provocations que vous connaissez je
pense parfaitement face à des pressions
gardent leur calme
ils ont subi beaucoup d'assaut un
certain nombre d'entre eux a été blessé
je les ai rencontrés avec le ministre
détermine l'intérieur pour l'emporter
notre soutien total et entier hier le
ministre d'état s'est rendue sur place
pour indiquer ce qui a été la position
constante du gouvernement à ceux des
occupants illégaux qui peut être
n'aurait pas compris la détermination du
gouvernement que soit ils rentraient
dans un processus de respect de la loi
soit il en tirerait les conséquences
et ils seraient exclues des parcelles
qu'ils occupent illégalement c'est très
exactement ce que nous avons dit
monsieur le sénateur mais c'est très
exactement ce que nous allons faire nous
allons le faire avec le souci d'éviter
les incidents
nous allons le faire avec le souci de
permettre aux gendarmes d'exercer leur
mission de remplir leurs missions dans
des conditions de sécurité maximale mais
nous avons le fermer
le sénateur sans charade sans légèreté
avec une masse détermination avec une
force tranquille dont je ne voudrais pas
que vous puissiez d'août et le début du
commencement d'une seconde jour merci et
à quelques semaines le président de la
république souhaitait commémorer mai 68
il faut croire que les bloqueurs de fac
lourde entendus ils sont en train
d'exercer son voeu alors madame la
ministre
quel est le choix du gouvernement est-il
bercé par la nostalgie de mai 68 et
comme à notre dame des landes le
rétablissement de l'état de droit se
limitera aux discours où le gouvernement
est il fermement décidé à user de son
autorité pour qu'une minorité militante
ne gâche pas l'année universitaire de la
grande majorité des étudiants
c'est effectivement une minorité
d'étudiants qui font entendre leur voix
et pour certains d'ailleurs et sur
certains lieux ce ne sont pas des
étudiants qui sont là et qui occupe sur
ses bancs comme sur d'autres banques
certains soutiennent cette minorité
d'étudiants en écoutant pas la très
grande majorité des étudiants qui je les
ai encore rencontré ce matin souhaite
effectivement étudier et passer leurs
examens
c'est pourquoi je les dis le premier
ministre l'a dit et l'ensemble du
gouvernement le dit
les examens se tiendront et cette année
ne sera pas une année blanche
il en va de la crédibilité de visiter
ces diplômes jour merci merci va
l'amener à midi
[Musique]